there's this amazing clip that was
posted online showing a husband and wife
in the middle of a disagreement you know
what I'm talking about yeah it's now
gone viral this is real here it is
Oh
buzzer wife yes right at me right now
okay
my god it's amazing so far that video
has been viewed millions of times and
got us interested we looked into it
apparently that's not the only clip of
that couple that was posted online it
looks like they were driving around like
that for a while take a look
hey Greg hey can I call you back
hey ma'am this one's for you sir
go ahead slow it down next time thank
you I'm saying honey come on
hey kiss I protest out of school one
honey don't do this honey
come on
anybody honey don't sell the car if you
love you
[Applause]
you